tim is a nun the Nobel assembly at
Karolinska Institute has today decided
toward the 2014 Nobel Prize in
Physiology or medicine with one-half to
John Okeefe and the other half jointly
to hybrid monster and edvard moser for
their discoveries of cells that
constitute a positioning system in the
brain the new belt exam long and
Karolinska Institute at hoy - Lawson the
Nobel Prize in Physiology or medicine
the service 3015 so helped on John
Okeefe who helped demise them a Madrid
Moser on edvard moser Farina and takumin
from Shannon young position even system
inherent buildin suit rely on La Salette
Nobel the last et Karolinska a desides
aru the tribal Cree Nobel Physiology or
medicine de milquetoast Katia John
Okeefe a poem watch a contra and more a
Madrid most advanced pool deck avert the
Saline kakan City assistant position Don
Loserville no bloody assembly a pre
Karolinska Institute referee Livonia
prestige noble obscure premio
official Oggy limited scene onnu
Palladino John Okeefe if - Rui Palladino
rad no my breath most revered Moser
South Korea clear talk Kotori establish
positional system Oh Google our norms
Mozgov thank you that was the
announcement I liked how to introduce
our expert panel here in the middle is
professor Julian serie professor of
physiology and chair of the Nobel
Committee
and to her right is Professor Hans force
pay an expert in clinical neuroscience
and the next to me here professor
Ulla keen who is a professor of
neuroscience and in the whole we also
have professors an eternal Bay and for
killing value who are members of the
Nobel assembly and experts in the field
now houla keen will give a brief
introduction to you about the laureates
and their discoveries and then we'll be
happy to take questions thank you good
morning
so here is this year's Nobel laureates
in Physiology or medicine on the left is
John Okeefe who is a professor at
University College in London and in the
middle is my producer who is professor
Norwegian University of Science and
Technology Trondheim Norway and on the
right is a husband and cooler ed Edward
Musa who is also professor in Trondheim
so this year's Nobel laureates have
discovered key aspects of an advanced
positioning system in the brain and in a
GPS that makes it possible to know where
we are and find our way the ability the
abilities to know where we are and find
our way are essential to our existence
for example how can we know we are in
the square in front of the concert hall
in Stockholm and how can we know how can
we find our way from the concert hall to
another place in the city for example
the city hall and how can we store this
information so we can find our way the
next time we take the same path these
abilities are governed by activity in
the brain or we're in the brain
the Positioning System located that
allows to perform these tasks and how
can the brain computes such complex
intellectual functions the work by the
Nobel laureates have given us answers to
these questions John Okeefe discovered
the first component in this Positioning
System he was really fascinated about
how the brain can create behaviors and
in the late 1960s he addressed this
problem by recording nervous nervous EVT
in feeling moving rats he recorded from
an area in the brain called hippocampus
which is shown here in orange and much
to his surprise he found in hippocampus
nerve cells that were only active when
that rat was in a certain position in
the environment his findings are shown
in this animation where the rat is
moving in a white fox and you can follow
the path of the rat by looking at the
great race and you can see whenever the
rat is in this position there is
activity in the cell in hippocampus he
is shown by the orange dot so Keith
called these cells play cells because a
cell was only active in a certain
position in a certain place in the
environment different play cells in the
hippocampus are active in different
places here indicated by the different
colors of cells in hippocampus and
O'Keefe therefore concluded that the
activity of these cells create an inner
map of the environment the same
combination of play cells was active in
the rat visited the same environment but
if it visited a new environment a new
combination of play cells would be
active
who keep therefore concluded that the
play cells in hippocampus generate many
inner maps of the environment which give
them information about where we are and
how we can recognize new environments
who keeps discoveries of play cells
showed that specialized nerve cells can
compute abstract higher brain functions
his finding had dramatic impact on the
story of how the brain creates behavior
more than 30 years of the O'Keefe's
original discovery of play cells
my Britt Musa and Edward Moussa found
another component in the Positioning
System they were recording from cells in
the entorhinal cortex which is strongly
connected to hippocampus and they
discovered a complete new type of nerve
nerve cell activity a certain type of
nerve cells in the inter-island cortex
were active not in one place but in many
places in the environment here shown by
the blue dots strikingly when the
Moose's do lines between the places and
environment where the cell was active
they discovered that the activity
pattern looked like a hexagonal grid
they record these cells grid cells
different grid cells build up the the
pattern of the with cells is slightly
shifted in environment so that the
hexagonal cover the entire environment
so activity in many grid cells they ever
provide the brain with a coordinate
system that divide the environment into
longitudes and latitudes that allows us
to keep track on how far we are from a
starting point and the turning point
the discovery by my bird Musa an Edward
Musa of the grid cells showed that the
brain can create a mental representation
of a coordinate system that can be used
for navigation in the external world the
next slide summarizes their findings
showing the bit cells in the entraron
cortex here in blue and the place cells
in the hippocampus in in yellow these
two those doctors are connected so you
have a coordinate system in the intron
cortex and a map in in the hippocampus
grid cells together with other cells of
the entorhinal cortex form a connected
circuitry with clay cells in hippocampus
this nerve cell network constitute a
comprehensive positioning system and in
a GPS in the brain recent works work in
humans have shown that humans also have
plays like cells in hippocampus and grid
like say cells in inter on cortex so
these findings suggest that we possess a
positioning system similar to the one
found in rats
so the discoveries by the Nobel
laureates provided a paradigm shift in
our understanding of how groups of
specialized nerve cells work together to
execute our brain functions the work has
open new avenues for studying how
cognitive processes are integrated and
computed by the brain thank you very
much for your attention
[Applause]
Hulan and now we're ready to take
questions Swedish or English spell
Schuyler engelska journals Egan yes it's
a fantastic set of discoveries we're
really excited
please
he'll forced me how many for Teague do
man you can't even though so they
decided behold some achieve their own El
Celler a mannequin siano didn't doctor
plastic London never okay
mediator Thompson's yet on woody Jana so
with Alzheimer example elderly male
formative eight who Tom Hereward honor
means gal on the victims progressive
with the a doctor at eternity years into
man at went up a locals in that
atmosphere water heater eight Ian him
member million so defecates until it
over at the head Jim torment we all
signed commercial what the hell she
statement públicas when the physics
Andhra till stones didn't moral
Samaritan before keys of Sheikh - maybe
Andhra yang to my look to commando for
problem madam hell
I can say at the Herald so it here on
14th please they hope take them all to
turn on hitter any hitter a little more
on
my coma shake
Nadia - Mariana clear Oh God
Helen I'm here for let Systema T Blount
Andhra order and they give a sample for
girl all the calls in there but on
sooner sadly Rock so can we do it in
English so the question is if other
animals and rats have the system and if
if it's similar to if first use this
system when they navigate what that's
the question what has been shown is that
both quiz which cells and play cells are
fine found in in rodents it's found in
bats it's fine in monkeys and now also
shown in humans so it seems to be a
system that is in in all mammals all the
vertebrates also have hippocampal like
and in tirana like structures so it
might also be found in in fish whether
it's exactly all the components of this
is used in Birds is not completely known
there are magnetic fields that the birds
might use for their further navigation
but what is characteristic for this
system is that it's it's not dependent
on one sensory input it's a combination
of many sensory input that creates the
activity in the place cells and in the
grid cells
so maybe a tenth addicted Mariella for
Klarman a flatter merciful or remember
oh please I'm freelance journalist for
Channel Radio my question is these
discovery then what's the significance
of that will it indicate that you can
find the better for example hemorrhage
and other diseases for the brain it's
similar to the previous question we had
in Swedish but it's very clear that
there are many processes in the brain
and this is one function one process
which has been described it's not
describing the mechanisms of brain
disorder it's a consequence of a brain
disorder as you have a brain disorder
like you said a hemorrhage or Alzheimer
we took as an example and that disease
will disturb these circuits so you will
have an impaired function so we are on a
functional level and the neural circuit
level but not on disease mechanisms that
we cannot use so again a prize for a
fundamental discovery of how the brain
works likely to give important results
and inspiration for research about
diseases in the future but no immediate
Verity based on this more questions
appear please
question is are the gender differences
in the positioning system of the brain I
don't know I think that I don't even
know but I think that the experiments in
rats weren't done in both male and
female rats I think is that what you are
aiming so this is just we don't know
about the particular the grid cells and
the places but we know about the sense
of place and navigation and there yes
there is a gender difference in humans
one half of us can navigate better than
the other if you look on an average okay
more questions if not I hope we have not
completely satisfied your curiosity and
there would be opportunities for those
of you who have requested interviews to
speak to members of the Nobel Committee
and those who you haven't should contact
mrs. dumansky here who can help you find
a committee member to interview we have
some secrets over there why means homes
for space that means I'm Nathan all bye
and xx happens to meet all the key and
I'll put it up here because I'm sure you
have already forgotten it
formal part of the press conference and
now we switch to introduce thank you
very much
[Applause]